[Music]
like how am i sounding welcome to
another edition of hot boxing with Mike
Tyson Mike what's up my brother another
day in paradise and today we've got the
man Tito Ortiz in the house
Zito thank you so much for being here
yeah now thank you so much for having me
man appreciate it you know I was just
telling you before this I grew up
playing a video game with you in it the
UFC video game on Dreamcast and that's a
trip
but man I mean I think that the best way
to start this thing off is to you know
for me knowing a little bit about your
life story you know you've faced a lot
of adversity in your life and to get to
you know the point where you're a UFC
champion you know you were at the you
were at the pinnacle of your profession
of your art form and you know what's
that like man how did you get from you
know a kid in Huntington Beach
California to UFC champion and and who
you are today Wow how much time do we
have to I guess it started you know at
the age six living in Huntington Beach
life was normal you know my father was a
carpenter
my mother was live at home mother and
life was just I got to school my mom
picked me up dropped me off
I come home play with my friends you
know we grew up in the punk rock era my
brother just smoked weed they drank and
pushed weed on me and you know at a
young age like that I got exposed to it
but at the age of about seven my father
had a hernia and he had to go get
surgery and they had him
morphine and when he got out of the
hospital he was addicted to morphine and
his brother actually introduced him to
heroin and he can't became addicted to
heroin from age of seven I think to date
you probably still use and I've talked
to him a long time but from 7 to 13 I
lived in Santa Ana with him we moved out
of motels people's garages little
trailers I live really really a hard
life I see a lot of stuff his super
young age that probably should have
never seen my mother and father brought
me along you know at the age of 13 I was
in Natick gangs one of my friends got
shot and killed and my mother's seen
that and she told my father he gets
sober I'm taking her son away and a week
later he still would get sober and she
packed her stuff up when we left she got
remarried we back we moved back down to
beach and I seen a lot of stuff at a
young age I grew up at a super fast at a
young age I think I never got to enjoy a
childhood but at 13 to about 15 I was
hanging on the wrong people you know
smoking weed doing cooking here and
there drinking alcohol I'd be super
young age like that and I just exposes
something that the adults are exposed to
so I was just doing it to be cool or to
be a part of the gang or be a part of
the people I was hanging out with my
freshman year in high school I found
wrestling or wrestling found me my true
name is Jacob I'm in the Bible Jacob
wrestled against angel angel be Thomas
he had his life and wrestling has saved
my life I grinded at wrestling it was
just something that I knew I could
become great at it and I started varsity
my first year there and I was just when
I walked into the wrestling room I've
always been a huge WWF fan which didn't
mean ow
I watched cold Colgan Macho Man Randy
Savage Tito Santana junkyard dog I mean
I grew up watching his guys and walking
to the wrestling room one wow where's
the ring in the coaches laughing I mean
that's the different type of wrestling
man that's very fast and this is this is
college or
pick style dress and I was like I still
get the slam guys in their head right it
goes well if you can you can do it and I
go I'm not gonna get in trouble right
they go now of course you can not gonna
get in trouble this competition I was
hitched I was hooked I was I was just
something I had thought that I could
become great at and like I said I
started varsity in my first year and I
just got better and better each and
every year and it was just from the hard
work and dedication through wrestling
and um CIF champ
yeah CIF champ took six in the state
third in the Masters on my senior year I
was only after three years 3.5 years of
wrestling that's awesome when I
graduated high school I told my mom you
know I'm gonna go live on my own and I
thought life was easy I thought it was
just kind of walk in the park and kind
of realize it's savage out there man
life is hard life is tough you there's a
lot of demands mercy no mercy and and
everybody will walk all over you if they
can they'll take everything from you
they'll rape everything from you and I
didn't understand that and I got a job
at a light moving service I was a mover
I worked 16 hour days and there were
hard long days how old at 18 years old
well and I couldn't keep up with the
time I was like I had to wake up super
out of the morning out of work super
late at night and in high school we'd
dab around with crystal methamphetamine
and all of a sudden I started doing it
again out of high school and I got
addicted to it and that was making me
work you know I was grinding 16-hour
days no problem partying at night wake
up the morning doing it every single day
I'm at probably at the end of that year
I was at a club and one of the wrestling
coaches that I seen when I was growing
up in high school came out to me he's
like Tito hue man yeah what's up coach
what do you do with yourself now well
I'm just making ends meet you know I'm
paying my bills my apartment and you
know working had a moving service place
you'll see me thought about coming back
in wrestling I was like I would love to
I just don't really have no financials
to take care of the college not know for
the books he's all I could possibly get
your financial aid man cuz you looking
good looking good flying not recognizing
it at all huh I went home that night and
I looked in the mirror and
I was saying hi to them now 63 you know
185 pounds I'm on 230 right now whoa
and I was sucked up pimples all over my
face and I look in the mirror I didn't
recognize myself and it scared me
because I was turned into my parents hmm
I had a really heart shaking reality
that I had to check myself and it was
just a question I still do to this day
always question myself I look in the
mirror and I say what are you doing
yourself right now do you want to turn
to your parents and I was like no I mean
thank God my mother's sober now my
father I'm not Hardison sure if he is
but it was hard it was a challenging
point in my life that I had to make a
decision and at that point I made the
decision I called my work I got home
that night slept all day Monday when I
wake up call my work and I said I'm not
gonna better come in today they're like
well we need you here I'm gonna go check
out this College thing no we need you
here we need it for this shift I was
like I can't come in like well you're
fired ago you know what I guess I quit
walking to the wrestling room actually
walked into the coach's office at
Goldman's junior college and I said I'm
here I want to try I want to see what
this college can really give back to me
I want to wrestle again I want to get to
I want to get a college degree and he
smiled he says do you know I think we
could help you how many financial aid
and I got a stipend because I'm Mexican
American I got went through college I
won the state title that year and good
Golden West junior college and then I
started training with the guy in two by
the name of tank Abbott thank ya you
know back in he's in the beginning stage
yeah I do see six so his wrestling coach
is Paul Herrera who was my high school
wrestling coach and he was like hey
coach n come train with tank early he's
not gonna punch me right boxer all the
wrestlers I never understood the Bison
crazy is a monster but a wooden wrestle
with him and I would take him down at
will I mean it was it was easy and
people the coach was like looking but
who is this kid and like I said I was a
state champion at the time for Golden
West Junior College 195 pounds and I
just thought that you know maybe I could
do this fighting thing I watched a UFC
13 I think it was Jerry Bohlander who
won the tournament he's submitted Kevin
Jackson who was a gold medalist in
wrestling for the United States
and he submit him in the finals and all
that kind of change Bolander it's been
named what's really familiar and I look
back at my high school wrestling God
beats and I wrestled him and I beat him
I think I was like attended to
well I was like wow I want to get chance
to this I told tank it would take man
gave me a fight of this I want to try
this man he was huh huh you want to
fight in this you sure you know I want
to own travel the travel trailer with
you I mean I got boxing guys I'm working
with I got my hands are pretty heavy I
mean I want to learn I don't want to do
this because alright well see we can do
and then May 30th in 1897 I got my first
try as an alternate I was in college I
was a scholarship student at the time so
I couldn't compete as a professional and
so I fought for free well first and only
UFC fighter to ever fight for free and
really that's how much I mean I love to
compete I want to see how good I truly
was and I fountain was it Augusta
Georgia
Yosi 13 May 30th 1997 and I stopped the
guy
Wes Allbritton in 22 seconds and also I
think that day a star was born man I was
those fortunate you know I came back
home and I went back to college cuz I
went to golden RC able to Cal State
Bakersfield I got a full ride to Cal
State Bakersfield me and the coach
didn't see eye to eye there and I end up
leaving coming back to Huntington Beach
I got a job at Spanky's adult novelty
store I sold I sold porn came back and I
fought three times dominate my next
three opponents
I fought Frank Shamrock for the world
title and I lost in the end of the
fourth round it was just by exhaust and
he was just professional who understood
the game and I was just a young kid who
just had a ton of heart and I pushed him
as hard as I possibly could but I end up
losing to him I went back to work at
Spanky's and the owner there poking his
sinuses Tito We Need to Talk and I
thought I was in trouble is like what do
you mean We Need to Talk he's a guy
coming off to sit down I sat down he's
like I don't this jobs for you because I
he goes out I watched you fight he goes
you're very impressive and you're
vicious I go but I need this job it pays
for my apartment piercer Midas plus cell
phone pays for my food
I got I need this job because I just
don't these jobs for you got dude I need
this job please calm down okay
but I'm here I'm early all the time I
work overnight shifts I mean I put it in
extra towers I mean I I need this money
goes how about this I'll give you a
sponsorship where I'll pay for your
apartment I'll pay for your phone I'll
pay for your food and all you do is
train I swim the biggest smile on my
face it was just like oh my god are you
serious yes yeah I watched you fight
against Frank Shamrock who's
professional and you always beat him
because if you won't work in the night
sleep the night shifts here I think he
could have been ready for the fight you
would have been killing the world
champion I was like wow dude and it was
Dyer blessing I mean in total and an
angel or looking over me or something
but he took care of me financially for
the next year my next fight was against
Wanderlei Silva for the vacant world
title and I became the first middle
weight world champion met skin' American
middle a world champ for UFC and I
defend him about five consecutive times
one of the longest reigning him until
Jonny bones Jones beat it but I think a
star was born and I of hard work and
dedication of always doing the right
thing and I've I've 21 years fast
forward now I'm still competing man so
much in there dude I mean that's just
that's just a little highlights you
understand I mean the stuff that I
treasure the stuff I went through as a
young kid I mean that's what makes me
work so hard and the not only just
nothing I'm just in life yeah life in
general yeah you know I I'm not a
religious person I have gone to a
Christian Church I have followed some
Mormon people I mean I have looked in
every sample dabbled in everything kind
of understand that it's a whole realm of
it all means the same thing as being a
good race and treating people the way
you want to be treat it and always be
respectful and never step on anybody to
get ahead hmm and I've kept that to my
heart and you know at the other day I
I'm an American who works hard I work
hard for what I have you know I paid
millions and millions and millions of
dollars in taxes and I've made millions
of dollars
but when my children are happy and they
have smiles on their faces I'm gonna
have three boys Jacob who's sixteen
Jesse and journey who are nine years old
when they could come home and they can
hop on me and saying dad I love you and
they put a smile on my face and it's
like I know I'm doing the right thing
when they're only in the fourth grade my
youngest and they're reading at a sixth
grade level their grades are as my
oldest his grades are A's I'm doing the
things my parents weren't doing you know
I'm looking out for their education
which is super important and I was
spending time with them not being there
with them they're not gonna feel the
want for love and I could feel the want
for affection from their father as I
missed out on it and I missed out a lot
of it and it
it's my doubt not my downfall I think
it's my strength that I try to bring
that I try to give them everything that
never had as a kid yeah I mean but at
the same time I make it through hard
work and dedication I don't give them
things that's like okay here here you go
here's clothes here's an item or I am
iPad or an iPhone they don't have
iPhones they'll have Xbox they don't
have none of that no it's not another 15
years old they can't do any of that
maybe on the weekends we'll play just a
little bit if they earn it they got
earned they got to earn everything
everything they have they earn anything
yeah and I took these little working
checking point just to actually realize
to notice that because my oldest Jacob I
would give him everything and I come to
realize that he felt entitled he's a
sure he gave it to me that time I can
have it now it's alright I got had to
kind of revamp it completely and redo it
and I'm ready right with my twin boys
yeah my oldest son actually is in
Arizona with my ex-wife and she does an
amazing job as a mother with him but
it's just one of those things we all get
second chances in life yeah I want to
wear another a lot of things we do yeah
and you giving your your eldest son
everything that he could possibly want
was out of you know that desire for you
to make a better life for your kids yeah
well it can you had it was just uh I
knew it the dirt tastes like right I
know it wanting something felt like you
know I had to steal for things know I
had to steal for food I had to steal for
clothes my parents never give a [ __ ] you
know they've made tried roof over my
head that was pretty much it you know my
mom did the best that she can do my
father
as best as he can do with a drug problem
my mother got clean for me and I was
lucky for it she changed my life and
we've had a mini sit down and talks
because I came out the book called this
is gonna hurt
it's kind of an autobiography of but I
lived through hmm and I had to tell her
because I had there are some secrets in
there that no one knew and she was like
I can't believe you said this thing so
like mom can understand those are the
things that I lived through she was yeah
but that made me look bad I go but mom
you did those things to make sure that I
always be able to survive it was super
tough for you understand but there's
other kids that are growing up that live
in exactly the same lifestyle exactly
the same realm and they don't think I'm
my self-worth they don't think they can
make it add the ghetto they don't think
they can make it out of the streets or
their parents being drug addicts and
being able to make something of
themselves and I have been able to do
that you know and I've watched Mike's
history of the things he's done in
person who I look up to and I admire
because we all have our demons on the
inside of us we try to make the best we
possibly can for our futures and Mike is
gonna hand and fist over like no other
and I'm still trying to work to make
that happen I just it's this challenging
to be a human being on this earth yeah
and to be beat in a respectable way and
um
okay I'm still doing a good job though
yeah so there were some turning points
in your life where somebody believed in
you and were able to like inspire you to
do better um yeah you know I there was a
couple you knows of course wrestling
coach Paul Herrera who helped me out in
wrestling and those are the times that
he would wake up I'm kind of my house at
7:00 in the morning we had to go cut
weight I'm gonna had 15 pounds to cut to
make the wave he would sacrifice he was
doing it for any extra money he was get
paid any extra money he was doing it
just to I don't know challenge me or to
give me the opportunity to make the
weight to wrestle as hard as I possibly
could but there was the wrestling coach
at Goldman Junior College who looked out
and see a troubled kid who was gonna go
down the wrong area it gave me an
opportunity but you know at the end of
the day I think I had to look in the
mirror myself and recognize those things
to take responsibility for my action
and not blame it on anybody else yeah
that's super important that's what our
organization standing and I did that's
what we do is there's a lot of people
out there struggling and they don't know
which way to go because when they're
stuck with their demons all day just
tripping on stuff and they don't know
way out and they get involved in you
know with the gangs and the mad and the
heroin and what we do is we're out there
in the trenches you know and when
someone raises their hand and they want
some help we're able to guide them and
show them the way out you know get a
minute detoxes or programs or jobs we
work a lot of homelessness we worked a
lot of facilities out there that you
know that'll give these guys a shot and
you know that was the greatest thing
that ever happened to me and my life was
a mentor somebody to show me the way out
just like I had the privilege of hearing
you at the treatment center giving back
to the guys there and motivating and
inspiring them that they can change it's
super important that they hear that
because when they're out on the streets
or they're you know just listening to
their own brains trying to figure a way
out they a lot of times to go back to
heroin they go back to meth and they
need an example and you're definitely an
example of overcoming adversity yeah you
know I have a few many many many times I
mean as many challenges I mean there's
times where I go back and I mean would
speed help me at this time and I was
like no I was so it was a horrible
feeling to be like that to be dependent
on something um you know and I at a
young age to have that I'm glad I did it
at a young age because as I'm older I
know what's right from I could confuse
right from wrong and make sure all the
right things but at the same time it's
just having the will you know yeah free
will as a saying hi I think about it
every single day and my kids is what
saved my life my children and their any
people out there who don't have children
and they're suffering by themselves and
they needed just responsible for their
actions and they were responsible for
themselves I am I think that's so
important is you know what you're saying
that's such a difficult thing for people
and I think increasingly difficult with
technology and all the [ __ ] that we see
and
you know trying to aspire to this idea
of perfection but you know it's all
about looking yourself in the mirror you
know and going you know what do I want
Who am I gonna be in this life you know
what am I gonna do with this life and it
says setting goals you know somebody the
point us in the right direction yeah we
need some guidance his mentor people to
believe in us yeah I mean like a higher
power yeah believe in a higher power I
mean at the same time I was always a guy
to look outside of television was my
learning curve
I learned the facts of life from
literally watching the facts of life
seriously watching it because I didn't
understand what love was you know watch
sure be watch that film I that's what me
understand what love was I'd understand
to know what hate was I got mad at
things but I don't understand I would
hate wasn't I watched a movie that was
that show but hate truly was and how a
person was able to get away from the
hate and to accept things that they were
doing and that's through my whole
childhood and I still do it I'm 43 years
old and I still do it while I watch
movies I don't watch a movie for
excitement for action I watch a movie to
see what the storyline is and what
they're trying to get out of it what is
it a per director producer trying to
explain in the film and I've learned so
much that I could actually you know
realize what's going on and what's the
truth and things no doubt man I think
movies and movies in particular have had
that played that role in my life for
sure yeah there's a film outlet called
The Shack and that's all that that movie
was just gone it was a deep deep deep
film you know it's about this guy who
actually goes out and he has hatred
because his daughter was killed was
raped and killed and he goes out and he
someone writes him a note and he
actually goes to the shack and he falls
hits his head and the story kind of gets
a little turned right there but he falls
his head and he goes back and it shows
the person who raped his daughter and he
says how can you judge this person if
you don't know his history and it shows
his history where his father was doing
the same thing to him
hmm and that's how the kind of the cycle
continued on and the movies great you
guys got a watch called The Shack right
don't waste too much time reading about
it but it was just almost things that
who was the star in the Sam Worthington
yes yeah yeah yeah it was like
forgiveness you know it was for
forgiveness isn't always about like
forgiving the other person it's a lot
more forgiving yourself for carrying
around this tree hugger came around this
anger you know and it's and then that's
some that I've learned I mean I think it
learned just this last year because I've
had so much hatred towards my father mmm
I never really understood it as I get
older now that I am 43 and I do
understand how a man I have kids and I
forgive him finally I like this you're
just this year I mean 43 I mean it's
been God 32 years that took me this long
just to forgive him because he was only
doing as good as he knew yeah as having
an addictive personality or having
having an addiction period to do as good
as he only could do and now it's hard to
accept things like that but a lot of
people if you live your life in the
agony pain of hatred it's gonna consume
your body completely be a negative
things like you're at I mean it'll
consume your body completely and it's
funny because I always look at people
and I say no I wonder how I can help
this person mm well that person has it
hard you know I can just help just a
little bit of so saying I guess it
probably that guy's a drug addict Allah
that guy's all that guy has some shitty
clothes on you know the way he carries
himself all that guy's horrible
once again it's feeding into the
negative ideas of things and I think
that is something that a lot of people
should not do is go out of your way of
saying walk to you person hey how you
doing how's your day today right just to
do just that little thing that took you
two seconds yeah a little kindness can
do clients will change someone's life
completely cuz I do it all the time ago
I mean I I'm a bigger guy 6 3 2 to 5 I
walked by and girl walks by I'm like hi
how are you
that's it she's like hi how are you and
just like put a smile on her face like
wow and a nice guy come walking by I'm
not saying a word I just being
standoffish to another person and I
think that's what humanity truly should
be is just being a good person and
reaching out to others and sometimes
they do need help or sometimes they knew
hey you're doing all right man
today you can make it through today man
today yeah this is a tough day but you
can make it through today and being
willing to give back that's super
important
absolutely sometimes it's really
difficult like a lot of people say you
know like love compassion kindness
forgiveness you know sometimes it
doesn't always come real easy and it
takes a lot of courage courage to
practice I mean courage is primary you
know they should step out and be
tolerant of people to be you know loving
towards people and to be compassionate
you know it sometimes it's uh you know
it does take a lot of courage to do
those things you know it can make the
difference between life and death
sometimes with someone giving them five
minutes sometimes you know we're talking
about our demons you know someone will
be wrapped up and you know I got a lot
of different treatment centers and
you'll see people that are just wrapped
up in confusion and pain and they want
to leave and sometimes just five minutes
of talking to him can make a humongous
difference in somebody's explanation you
know they don't wonder why you know
wondering that they're not the only ones
go dilling through that stuff yeah I had
a super interesting experience the other
day I was going on a hike with my wife
and we go over on Fryman Canyon and in
the valley and we're getting ready to
start on the hike and I see this dude
peeling out of the parking lot and his
trunk is like flying open and I could
tell it's not like he has something in
there that doesn't fit and he's got it
tied or something you know you might see
that sometimes so I like point because I
noticed it and I'm like I don't want
this guy's stuff to start flying all
over the place you know and he peels out
he's waiting at the stop light before
turning onto Laurel Canyon
and he sees me pointing and I'm like yo
you know about to say your trunk is open
and this guy full of piss and vinegar
even with
his car around makes a u-turn flies up
next to my wife my wife is so she's like
freaked out she's like I thought he was
gonna [ __ ] hit us
and I'm totally chill dude you know I've
been diving deep in my meditation I met
Emily I'm calm as hell and I realized
when this guy flips this u-turn like he
does I'm like oh this guy's pissed and
he's a young african-american dude and I
in my head I'm like he thinks I'm some
big white racist who's trying to start
some [ __ ] and he comes up he flies up
he's like yo yo [ __ ] what's a
[ __ ] problem and I'm like now dude
your trunk is open and he just like
couldn't believe checking reality that I
just was trying to help the guy out and
he's like and I'm like you want me to
close your trunk for you man and I go
over there I close this trunk and he was
so it was like he was frothing at the
mouth to have this confrontation and I
was like dude I'm just I didn't want you
to lose your stuff man cookies guy and
he was totally I felt like in that
moment I'd really sort of shocked him
because he was expecting to have this
aggressive confrontation and yet it was
just another human being trying to help
him out now you know it was really
interesting and it was cool man but
something you said Teta you know I want
to hit this you know with Danny here
your dad's heroin addiction started with
him going to the hospital and getting
hooked on morphine Greg you know that's
crazy that that happens to so many
people you know and well I mean I've had
eight surgeries myself I've had a CI
replaced my left knee ACL replaced my
right knee l 405's one fused on my lower
back
C was giving me a t3 t2 t2 t1 and c7
disc replacement well I meant C 67 fused
I've had C 4 C 5 disc replacement and he
gave me fight boys
I can't walk sometimes yeah fight I
challenged my mind I think it's about a
body challenge but I just challenge my
mind knowing that I could do it I I
believe in it and when I believe in it
and I let my body accept it it happens
you know I've been in 21 years of
competition but after having all these
surgeries every time I get down with the
surgery the pain goes away and I'm on
painkillers on vicodins you've been
prescribed you've taken up taking them
and it got to a point where just this
last year after my last neck surgery
I've had the three disc replacements
that I was on you high above it's 1,200
milligrams of vicodin per day and I got
to a point where my pain was gone but I
could feel I was always agitated and I
was yelling at my kids yeah and I was
like man I got to stop yeah New Year's
Eve in Las Vegas
I said I'm when I'm done I can't do this
anymore my my girlfriend went out with a
couple of friends and I stayed in the
hotel room and I cold turkey bit
well I sat in the hotel we were in there
for five days and then finally got our
car and drove back I remember hurting on
the way home sat in my room for another
two weeks
and it was the hardest thing and I ever
gone through but I was able to kick it I
was able to say you know what enough
s'en up and I wasn't in pain anymore
rolling the only pain that I was was the
addiction of eating painkillers right
and I was able to walk away from it and
you know I as a kid young kid you know I
was introduced to marijuana super young
but something to kind of take the
agitation of having the withdrawals from
pain cause was marijuana before him in
bed at night hotel
you know there's yeah there's so many
people out there right now that want to
get off the heroin that want to get off
the painkillers but that fear of
withdrawal that fear of detoxing it just
and then a lot of people they get on the
painkillers and then they go back to
their doctor and their doctor won't
prescribe him anymore and so now they're
withdrawing and lots of people they wind
up going to heroin right you know and
then they get strung out on heroin for
years yeah and a lot of them don't make
it you know
an epidemic right now I think that that
was one of the things that I would
suffer so bad from the detox out the
pain cuz you like sit up after eight
surgeries I've gone through eight times
yeah but seeing how my parents were and
see how they had my dad had everything
he had his own business everything and
he lost everything everything was lost
our our family was lost everything was
lost but that was my fear to never do
not heroin heroin was always the one
don't ever do it hammer because you will
lose everything because it's the worst
addiction that anybody could ever try
everywhere of anything I know and I've
always was lucky enough to stay away
from it but the painkillers were
something that I was subscribed by a
doctor you know my ex
Jen and Jameson she actually was
addicted to is or I don't know I haven't
talked to her in five years to
oxycottons okay and brutal she after one
of my fights I fought in 2012 against
Forrest Griffin I was bruised up my face
was banged up I was I was a little bit
of pain actually a lot of pain and she
went to go hand me wanna know what says
she goes that's an oxycontin and my
trainer was next to me so then I go and
I gotta clean it I knew exactly what it
was I mean it's yeah there is synthetic
yeah hormone and I don't know you take
us back you're not taking these rashes
no not you gotta for my friends and
that's when it all started I was in 2012
and it just got worse and worse and
worse and I can't see how people like I
can't see how people do it but I just
run I wish a lot more people would
recognize it and seeing how hard and how
bad it could change a person's life or a
family
I mean Roy's family's just one of those
things that you know the doctors don't
realize what that prescribed because
they're making money from it at the end
the day it's the high mighty dollar for
them and you know all the prescriptions
everything that are given out to America
or people across the world in general
you know there's other ways of helping
with those pains right I think marijuana
can fill that void definitely man
definitely that's a big thing that you
know I advocate for I played in the NFL
for six years you know handful of
surgeries back shoulder you know neck
pain and all that's dealt with is pillow
in the league you know and so addictive
goes yeah they do stuff in the violent
no no and that can all be remedied with
cannabis right now Mike you've had I
mean you've had your struggles with
painkillers what was that what was your
experience dealing with opiates and
stuff like that I love this stuff
awesome it took away the pain right away
I couldn't walk and the next thing you
know I could walk so I'm saying wow this
is heaven sake heaven taken that so I
went one day I was hanging out with my
wife and I just threw up I can't take it
anymore
but I still love this the buddies do up
and I started getting sick
oh they started me out with like yeah
yeah we're on detoxing yeah it's brutal
man
what'd they do to you I mean they can
help numb the pain Italian um yeah just
putting a bandage over yes actually the
temporaries doesn't let you heal crazy
yeah sometimes you know they'll you'll
have an injury and they'll give you some
therapy where you could probably get out
of that pain and recoup in like three
weeks maybe a month but they'll
prescribe you six months worth of
freaking oxycontin you know hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of pills that's
like it's it's insane it's crazy seeing
you know how you take the pain I can't
just do the pills my wife won't let me
take the pills we all get free scaring
the doctor give us the pills yeah yeah
yeah no needs either I see a cotton I
just don't understand how a doctor could
prescribe that knowing the side-effects
knowing the things that people go
through from it and how it ruins our
country love that stuff believe it Lima
and you love it boom take the way that
pain right away yeah but I mean
hopefully that thinking can get fixed
and you know with Canada making
marijuana legal you know hopefully the
rest the United States will follow the
suit as I think they had a pause the
future yeah yeah as Jennifer has I mean
all the other states are following so I
you know look at
was it Hollan I mean Holland man yeah no
problem with it yeah Portugal the same
they've legalized all drugs and drug
addiction has gone down you know it just
it's it's a wellness it's a well-being
issue for human beings you know I mean
and I think it separates people who
don't want to do it they won't do it
exactly people who are gonna do it
they're gonna be on a level of not
wanting to steal or not causing trouble
or right not doing the things that is
wrong in our laws right where there's a
lawful side of it that it's controlled
and I think that's super important yeah
no doubt have you dabbled in the CBD
stuff at all I did I am actually there's
a CBD drink that I just started sweet
yeah so that that was because I yeah I
do the lotion every night for my neck of
course I'm gonna have to have it all on
my disk yeah fused in disc replacements
I go through pain because I wrestle him
yeah doing jiu-jitsu guys are pulling on
my neck snapping me down front head get
in chokes on me and I gotta fight them
off yeah double legs hitting single legs
taking punches taking jabs right hands
uppercuts I mean head kicks too much
going on and you know like it's like you
get a boxing in the box these checkers
and then you got MMA or being chest and
you got two games you gotta figure out
who could win the game the right way and
in chess that's our game and it's so
hard because there's so many ways to win
the game but in boxing it's forward back
side to side with you you made a little
difference where it was for back side to
side up down I mean you changed angles
like no other I mean I still watch all
your network stuff your bag works thank
you and there's nobody in the world
who's ever hit a bag or hit mitts the
way you hit the FRA the frosya
are ferocious punches that you do yeah I
try to mimic when I train on my boxer my
boxing trains like what are you doing
I'm like oh I just say things Mike doing
man I stay you know I'm still trying to
get it just that mentality though it's
that mentality going out either kill or
be killed
sure that's the way you know in
competition or in life in general
sometime it's like you know it's a
vicious
cycle and I just I look up to Mike a lot
because through my whole career I've
I've always never wanted to be the
person that couldn't do it I've always
wanted to be the one to do it and
exactly I mean I remember back in 2001
at the MGM I seen a Mandalay Bay Mike
came walking in and you know he came sat
in my dressing room and he was sitting
down on the floor watching me hit pads
and I'll never forget this and he looked
up he goes you kick like a [ __ ] mule
and I was like dude this is Mike Tyson
on my [ __ ] dressing room right now I
was I mean I got a fan boy I'm not
pointing right there oh he's like it was
the coolest thing I came a t-shirt and I
said
Spanky's xxx on acid Tito Ortiz on it
and I had a flame beanie and then his
next bite when he felt fast while both
are you can walk him out with the
punishment flame beanie Mike that was uh
I was one of those times in my life
where I was like man this is pretty damn
cool as a kid what not watching you in
high school and then through my career
and just always being that one that
wasn't able to make it I mean I I don't
think my life compared to yours just
you've been through some great many
great things made challenges but I kind
of compare it as we've came from nothing
and we weren't supposed to make it and
we made it and we continued to do it and
were able to do it by showing through
our kids you know and they said the best
resemblance of a man is through his
child's and my children I'm happy about
it and make it man you are the same
thing I'm happy yeah that's great I mean
I just it's just one champ talking to
another one I just like I said I'm still
competing I still love it I still have
the hunger I still have the grind and I
remember Mike said not to quote exactly
but he's talking about walking to the
cage and people saying how do you feel
when you walk into the cage and he said
I'm in such fear of losing for my fans
losing for my family but by the time I
walked into the cage I'm
stoppable I walk into the ring I'm
unstoppable and every time I'm I fight
every time I walk out every single time
I get ready for my fight I had that same
mentality I'll be walking out I have
tears coming down my eyes because it's I
have the fear is leaving my body
so once I do step into the cage yeah I
feel invincible amazing and there's no
feeling in the world like it and I think
Mike's the only one could fill a feeling
like that or other fighters can feel it
feel like that because it's most
loneliest feeling in the world to be a
fighter yeah because it's do only you
you out get it up and train you got to
get up and run you got to get up and do
weight training you got to get up and
spar you got to get up and wrestle you
had to go through all these things and
then you go to get in the ring no one
else to help you survive oh yeah and
then it's a vicious vicious competition
but you know at the other day I got to
make sure I prepare for it and they say
I mean that's not a little story about
my amazing dude No thank you for sharing
that man what else man what what's on
the horizon for you as far as what do
you what are you doing with your life
acting oh yeah yeah mom I'm getting
opportunities you know I got to turn
down a lot of them cuz I won't be
stereotyped to the fighter guy I
pronounced someone fighter film so I I
want to get an opportunity just to show
my acting and it's still in a
development I still got to learn I still
got to work for really really really
really hard I mean the memorization of
lines I'm making sure you get the same
feeling of the lines they're trying to
get out of it
the characters you got to build I mean
yeah I think I excuse me in the acting
classes that I took helped out a lot to
find the character building the 20
questions of who this person is where
he's from who's his brother his dad what
was he doing he was 14 years old just
kind of love filling that character I'm
still learning it's still a process he's
acting coat um actually I worked with
Erin McPherson and of Beverly Hills
grief and use actually helped me on a
lot a lot of things another guy Patrick
Barbic that set of Beverly Hills also
nice and but I have other things that
I've worked on of course in 2005 I did
this Celebrity Apprentice with Donald
Trump our guys
and I was I was a guy questioning them I
was other guys asking him you know how
do you become a billionaire pretty super
done thank you appreciate thank you
juice delivery yes my former world champ
former UFC world champion ever dude very
very cool
that's awesome that's how we throw down
at Tyson ranch man right that's awesome
man acting yeah blowing like say when I
went back and I was doing this every
apprentice with Trump and I I always got
next to his side and everybody else that
were there doing it they were just
partying and doing their thing and I was
the guy next to him asking questions not
even sell a million how do you become a
billionaire what do you do to make your
businesses I mean I was question him
everything and he said well Tito one
thing I never stopped working
mm-hmm even when I'm sleeping I have
people working for me mm-hmm because if
you want to continue to stand a
millionaire you gotta have five sources
and kumkum told me everything
Ross yeah five sources of income streams
of revenue five standard revenue coming
in every year so I was like hmm so now
the sudden he staples something in my
mind he bran is up my mind that I have
not stopped working on since he told me
that cool so I have my clothing company
punishment athletic wear huh is strictly
for at them this tank
yeah it's anchored that's dope dude I'd
Rock one of those yeah I'll get you got
seen you guys some gear hello um and
then I started my car business it's
actually hotel car business at Mannheim
in Fontana
cauti Auto Group we run Lane nine we run
150 cars a week every Thursday I have a
management company which is called
primetime 360 with my partner Jorge
crazy gene we manage about 922 fighters
now I think we just signed her second
one
Don mad she just fought in the last UFC
one by knockout Cris cyborg eating
Talent oh yeah cuz I work to ice but
there's some a lot of new up-and-coming
talent but it's just made here if you
got any
yeah but you know I'm it's just one of
those things that are still looking for
that fifth one
you know this recur this fourth one
maybe this promotion with Oscar De La
Hoya doing Golden Boy MMA cool but the
acting thing I think is the fifth but
still it's just I could say it's a
process I mean it's it's a grind you got
to work every day doing and hotel but it
is an art you got to make sure you just
perfected it you know I look guys like
Dwayne Johnson oh great yeah he's
awesome yeah just shows the hard work
that he does he's always working working
working working and I respect that so
much it's the same grind that I've had
through my career of a fighting bud
Rhodes well if I'm able to kind of
transit that into that type of career I
would love to but you got to put in the
work no doubt man I've thought about
that myself getting into acting after my
NFL career and it's like man I busted my
ass on a straight line trajectory for 12
years before I made it to the NFL and
you know it's like okay if I want to be
an actor it's gonna take another decade
and ten years of hard ass work and focus
you know just chiseling away a little
bit at a time like you said man well man
I think that's it's pretty awesome dude
thank you for coming in today
really thank you yeah Mike I appreciate
it Mike yeah another great one brother
thank you as always
awesome all right guys until next time
we're out
[Music]